you turn now to the big recall election
in california today polls are still open
larry elder will join us live in a
moment earlier today leo 2.0 terrell
asking california's about that riveting
speech and the ongoing california recall
and watch closely there's somebody in
there that's been a guest on this show
take a look
who you vote for gavin newsom i voted to
keep gavin newsom as governor why do you
think gavin newsom doing a good job
uh i think to replace him would
possibly
be a disaster why you voted for larry
i met him one time
great guy
i like his i like what he stands for
and we need a change get to do some out
of here why get newsom out
because he's a crook let me ask you joe
biden came in yesterday what do you
think of joe biden
even worse if it's possible
gavin newsom done a horrible job what's
the problem with kevin
we'll let you start with the climate
change and the fires and the and the the
masks and the uh what he's done to small
business in this you know
i
it's time to go you're gonna vote for
larry elder okay tell me why you're
gonna vote for larry elder democrats are
ruining california let me ask you a
question i want you to decide who do you
like better leo trailer sean hannity
leotard
love you love you hear that shot
unbelievable anyway that was suzanne
summers also in that piece uh leo
terrell reporting joining us now larry
elder all right big night larry we uh
one thing we heard very i know i can't
win right um
we've heard early we won't have results
tonight probably correct even though
they've been voting for how many weeks
and how many days after election day can
actually correct a ballot or even vote
i think the secretary of state has about
30 days to do that but sean the lines
are long that's good news for our side
because the democrats trust the mail
they vote early but i'm hearing from
people saying i've been voting all my
life i've never seen lines like this and
and the reason that leo had the reaction
that he had is because this man's record
is indefensible on crime on homelessness
on the way he shut down the state a
third of all small businesses are now
gone forever we've only recovered about
half of our jobs pre-pandemic as opposed
to two-thirds nationwide people are
leaving california for the first time
citing high cost of living taxes
regulations eight hundred thousand
dollars is the average price of a home
in california that's 150 percent above
the national average bad forest
management running out of water uh our
energy grid is poor there's no front
where this man has done a good job
that's why all these people that have
come in
whether it's barack obama or elizabeth
warren or bernie sanders cut a
commercial for them none of them have
said the following magical word sean
gavin newsom has done a fine job for the
people of california
you know it's i i may have to say
governor-elect uh larry elder the next
time you're on the program and i'm
hoping uh i think long lines work in
your favor it's an uphill battle always
has been uh i'm hoping for a political
explosion out there
obviously electoral um in terms of uh an
upset here and we're watching very
closely and uh everybody has more time
to vote so get out there if you haven't
gotten out there larry elder good luck
we'll be watching closely hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else